[Musique]
ce lundi 18 avril Nassima Dindar
présidente du département s'est vu
remettre le label européen de
convivialité et de solidarité par
Athanas Périfan président de la
Fédération européenne des solidarités de
proximité et fondateur de la Fête des
Voisins une récompense remise au
département de La Réunion pour son
action menée autour de la solidarité
généreuse et des services mis en place
pour le mieux vivre
ensemble au fond j'ai envie de vous
résumer c'est bien l'objectif
final d'un
élu chaque fois qu'il travaille
l'objectif final c'est bien celui de se
dire que le but à atteindre il est celui
de garder
l'identité réunionnaise celle de
transmettre des anciens aux plus jeunes
des jeunes à l'adulte de demain la
solidarité créole qui a fait que ce
territoire est celui-ci qui a fait que
euh créoles arabes chinois oreilles
Malba CAF métis et ben nous l'a fait se
vivre ensemble qui reste quand même un
modèle et un modèle à
préserver cette séquence organisée lors
d'un café des aidents à permis aux
personnes présentes confrontées à des
difficultés de témoigner de faire part
de leur quotidien et parfois de leurs
souffrance le café des aidans un moment
privilégié d'échange et de
partage depuis le début ben je me suis
toujours retrouver dans ce dans ce café
je viens rechercher un peu de ben je dis
un peu de réconfort puisque ben je suis
maman d'une fille en situation de
handicap d'une quarantaine d'années oui
donc vous voyez que c'est pas évident de
vivre B tous les jours avec cet adulte
en venant au café des édans on rencontre
d'autres personnes il y a d'autres cas
on n'est pas les seuls et ça
réconforte on se retrouve donc on rigole
et puis on discute de tout et de rien et
on oublie nots tracasin quand je viens
ici ben c'est pour rencontrer de
nouvelles personnes et le fait de
partager une expérience les difficultés
qu'on rencontre surtout et quand on sort
de là surtout avec l'aide de la
psychologue ben souvent elle nous
apporte quelques petit point pour nous
aider à améliorer certaines choses pour
améliorer la vie de tous les jours et
puis on crée déjà aussi un lien d'amitié
avec les autres membres de ce groupe et
puis ben souvent c'est un bon moment de
rigolade et puis quand on sort de là ben
on est reboosté on est en forme et on
est reparti pour le mois en fin de
compte pour tenir jusqu'à la prochaine
fois un travail exemplaire selon Athanas
Périfan le président de la FESP souhaite
faire du département de La Réunion à
laboratoire d'innovation sociale au
niveau européen une zone
d'expérimentation pour développer les
actions menées sur l'île et pouvoir
ensuite l'exporter ailleurs
elle mérite un prix parce qu'en fait le
département de La Réunion fait des
efforts très conséquents il y a de très
nombreux projets innovants et croyez-moi
de très nombreux départements en France
et de nombreux territoir en Europe ne
sont pas aussi en avance que la
politique en faveur de la solidarité oui
la solidarité est l'affaire de tous les
départements peu de départements en
métropole mettent une telle énergie une
telle innovation la réalité c'est que la
solidarité c'est une affaire
institutionnelle mais la présidente a un
grand cœur on le sent tout à l'heure on
l'a vu et qu'elle a dans son ADN ce
partage cette fraternité qui est notre
troème devise
républicaine seuls trois territoires
européens se sont vu remettre ce label
auparavant l'île de la Réunion est le
deuxème département français à le
[Musique]
recevoir I